I know we were having a conversation
before we got going about the
competition online and how hard it is to
you know get people to see your work
right where do you stand on creating
things that audiences want to see and
may be willing to pay for versus
creating work that's meaningful to you
right and maybe it's gonna just be a
little niche audience right well I don't
think I've ever been any good at
thinking in terms of let me craft
something that's going to be a big
audience favorite because I think that
it's hard enough for the filmmaker or
for me to get interested in a particular
story anyway in other words I never felt
that I was even though I can execute any
story and I've done television I've done
things that were scripted I can I can
make that movie and I can make it
hopefully work to set out to make a film
that story has to be meaningful
personally otherwise I won't have the
strength to to go through the obstacles
and all the knows and it's not gonna
there has to be something driving that
for me personally so and I never thought
I was necessarily skilled as an
architect of that kind of audience
crowd-pleasing super commercial movie I
just hope that because I do love
commercial cinema there's plenty of
commercial movies that I love that
somehow buy that love will find its way
into whatever story I'm doing and they
will contain those elements but
hopefully will be more personal they
won't be as machined so yeah I you know
I'd probably be more I'd probably be a
wealthy man if I was you know skilled in
that you know in that connect but I
think the best people who do make
commercial movies and you can just
rattle me and I look going all the way
back to Spielberg or Michael Bay those
people that do make those movies they
are that's that's how they think in
other words it's not like I don't think
they're sitting around saying let's you
know make a commercial movie that maybe
on their mind but their tastes are
exactly that commercial thing so it just
happens that right the audience of core
is gonna connect because they are that
audience and that's their the perfect
they're the perfect people to make that
stuff otherwise everybody would be able
to do that if it was simply a matter of
like reading the instructions on how to
make then everybody would just go yeah I
want to be rich let's just do that and
it's not for lack of trying everybody
tries a lot of people try but for me I
have to find I have to find a story that
is valuable in some way to me and then I
can I'm happy to add on all the quote
unquote commercial components or
exploitative components or any of those
things that you find in a commercial
movie but at least the foundation is is
personal all right thinking of a movie
like um people maybe people disagree
with me but into the wild right so it's
about Christopher McCandless story and I
hadn't really heard of the book before
the movie came out right when I didn't
realize there was like this whole cult
following for this book but that's one
that it seems like you wouldn't expect
the audience to present even though I
think it's a fantastic film right and I
loved it but but it's a store it's a
very special story right you wouldn't
it's not about you know an everyday
thing but but somehow I was able to
resonate with millions of people right
well I think I think you're right
because I think it's probably because
the specific and then the nature of the
story about somebody based putting
themselves out into the into the
wilderness to that extreme it's not the
specific act that everybody can relate
to I think it's the internal thing that
the person is going through that people
connect with that's what I'm talking
about I mean there's something universal
in those kinds of feelings and I think
that's why for example they always talk
you know everybody involved a taxi
driver said this doesn't you know we're
making this for us but probably no one's
going to get it and then it turned out
to be this huge hit because there were
as a billion very alienated lonely angry
individuals out there that went oh my
god that's you know I identify with that
so I think we'd be a lot richer film
eclis if the business allowed for more
of those movies to be made because you
know a producer is not going to you know
is not is going to be looking for
something that is
obviously something that people can
relate to but but people are much more
complicated than than the way they're
depicted in Hollywood movies and so
every once in a while when something
presents a reflection of that
Munir I think it will be successful
because people like thank you thank you
for showing you know showing me that I
am represented as opposed to it just
being you know a cartoon or again an
advertisement for life so even something
like Legally Blonde which is a it's a
cute story and there's a great message
and I enjoyed the film uh-huh but it
makes light of someone that's sort of
ostracized right and in real life
someone probably wouldn't be well I'm
just gonna you know get all dolled up
and go in there and show them it's gonna
be you know a lot of pain behind the
scenes but it's definitely showing
something that many people have been
through right but in a light way where I
feel safe well that's that mean and
that's bound to be the more commercial I
mean if you can somehow illustrate those
really painful awkward things in a way
that manages to be entertaining or safe
which I think is a really good word
because most people go to the movies as
a you know they go to the movies they
take it like a tonic they're not they're
not going to be unless you're going to a
torture porn you know you're not going
to be ripped apart you're going to be
soothed
so camouflaging or or sugarcoating or I
don't know how you put it real things in
a Hollywood way I think is a real that's
a real art and a real trick and if that
can happen you know like for example
like for me like I resisted Groundhog
Day
like when Groundhog Day came out I was
like this is just a one-note thing I
think most people thought that how this
guy wakes up every day huh and then when
you actually watched the movie and you
know Harold Ramis this has been Bill
Murray do this brilliant job of getting
at a lot of real deep things in this
very silly gimmicky movie and that was
obviously their intent you know that
that dealing with somebody who was
bitter and it given up and doesn't give
a about people anymore and has
disconnected and just a user and then
through this
this twist of fate now has to like go
through the stages of processing that
totally becomes like a human being you
know if you'd made a straightforward
movie about that without the gimmick I
don't think it would be that as popular
necessarily people wouldn't go to see it
but with the twist and the comedy I'm
say that again but with the twist and
the comedy and the Bill Murray aspect
the whole thing it becomes this much
more pleasurable pill to swallow and a
surprise in a way and that's why I like
I love that movie because it's like wow
I thought this was this superficial
shitty thing and it turns out to be
actually a quite complex interesting
movie and I love that I mean I and there
are times where I want my message or my
identification in an ice-candy package
we don't always want it you know rough
you